könntet ihr euch vorstellen nicht 40
nicht 60 aber auch nicht 80 sondern 100
stunden pro woche zu arbeiten wenn man
dreimal so viel arbeit wie üblich
schafft man in vier monaten das wofür
andere das ganze jahr brauchen zumindest
in der theorie da man wenn man 100
stunden pro woche arbeitet entweder
komplett ausgelaugt ist und unproduktive
wird oder sogar zusammenbricht ich mache
das experiment und finde heraus wird
sich auf meinen körper meine gesundheit
mein sozialleben aber auch auf mein
business auswirkt wenn ich diese woche
100 stunden arbeit
dieses video wird unterstützt von sap
der software die steuern und buchhaltung
endlich erträglich macht zuerst was man
anmerken dass das was ich vorhabe für
angestellte zurecht absolut verboten ist
es ist in deutschland streng geregelt
wie viel man arbeiten darf und
arbeitgeber müssen gott sei dank mit
hohem sanktionen rechnen selbst seien
angestellte freiwillig mehr als erlaubt
arbeiten die regel bei
vollzeitbeschäftigung sind acht stunden
am tag fünf tage die woche womit man auf
eine 40 stunden woche kommt und selbst
mit überstunden sind zehn stunden pro
tag das absolute maximum und bis auf
einige ausnahmen zu denen unter anderen
krankenhäusern gastronomie oder die
filmbranche zählen klappt das
hierzulande auch relativ gut
arbeitnehmer haben selbstverständlich
ein anspruch auf bezahlten urlaubs und
krankheitstage außer sie leben in
amerika und ja also ich das
herausgefunden aber ich selber recht
schockiert ist stellt euch vor ihr könnt
eure miete nicht bezahlt nur weil er mal
eine woche krank sei deutschland liegt
europaweit mit 40,3 stunden pro woche
genau im mittelfeld die
durchschnittliche arbeitszeit ging in
deutschland seit den 60ern übrigens
bereits um circa 33 prozent zurück und
wenn ihr mich fragt kann das gerne so
weitergehen weil auch mit 40 stunden die
woche lebt man eher für die arbeit als
dass man arbeitet um zu leben okay aber
warum wir nicht 100 stunden arbeiten
es ist kompliziert zum einen möchte ich
euch gerne zeigen wie so ein extremer
alltag aussieht und wie er sich auf die
einzelnen bereiche des lebens auswirkt
weil ich selbstständig bin und meine
arbeitszeiten von kein gesetzen
eingeschränkt wird und ich habe mal
wieder verdammt viel zu tun und jede
sekunde zählt tag eins extrem frühes
aufstehen eine automatisierte morgen
routine
stromlinienförmige abläufe um die zeit
möglichst effizient zu nutzen sind das
woran er jetzt wohl gedacht hätte aber
ich kann uns gestern einfach ewig nicht
einschlafen jetzt ist es schon neun uhr
und ich wollte eigentlich um 6 uhr
aufstehen
das ist kein guter start in die 100
stunden arbeitswoche
nichtsdestotrotz gehe ich sofort ins bad
und macht mich fertig ohne zeit zu
verschwenden und so brauche ich zum
beispiel fürs duschen nur drei minuten
jetzt geht's an den schnitt des videos
für samstag
aber bevor hier irgendwas gedreht oder
geschnitten wird muss ich natürlich erst
mal büro erfolgen weil auch wenn ich
eigentlich sehr menschen überhaupt bin
ist mir wollten und tatsächlich ziemlich
wichtig vor allem wenn ich filme weil
der das bild einfach schöner aussieht
werden halt ein pralles aufgeräumt ist
[Musik]
arbeit ist natürlich eine frage der
definition es gibt das alte sprichwort
von konfuzius wähle einen beruf den du
liebst und du brauchst keinen tag in
deinem leben mehr zu arbeiten
vielleicht mache ich etwas falsch aber
selbst der absolute traumberuf den ich
meinen nennen darf und durch nichts
austauschen würde ja selbst der fühlt
sich absolut nach arbeit an arbeit dazu
später mehr
damit ich diese woche möglichst viel
arbeiten kann werde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht großartig dazu kommen die wäsche
zu waschen aufzuräumen zu kochen oder
einzukaufen um zwei fliegen mit einer
klappe zu schlagen wenn ich also neben
diesem video parallel noch ein zweites
tränen in dem ich eine woche lang jede
mahlzeit beim lieferdienst bestell die
ersten beiden tage sind recht
unspektakulär das meiste was ich in
dieser woche arbeiten muss ist schneiden
und das erstellen von konzepten und das
ist für mich auch mit abstand das mental
an strengste da das aber relativ
langweilig zum zu sehen ist erspare ich
euch das größtenteils und versuche euch
die spannenderen dinge zu zeigen am
ersten tag arbeite ich bis 2 uhr nachts
womit wir abzüglich der einen stunde und
zehn minuten pause auf 17 stunden
arbeitszeit an tag 2 stehe ich wieder um
neun uhr morgens auf aber da ich dass
wir schnellstmöglich fertig haben muss
[Musik]
habe ich bis 6 sobald sich durch
gearbeitet das video enthält nämlich an
frank renger und das möchte der kunde
natürlich gleichzeitig sehen weil er hat
sich eineinhalb stunden pause tutorial
fertig übrigens auch die zeit die ich
morgens und abends braucht um mich
fertig zu machen als auch essenszeit
hessens pad in einer stunde um 37 macht
sich meine freundin bereit in ihren tag
zu starten deswegen schlafe ich im büro
auf der couch erstens damit ich sie
nicht weg von 21 damit ich nicht nach
einer stunde wach werde am zweiten tag
habe ich also glatt 20 stunden
gearbeitet
ich wache nach nur viereinhalb stunden
auf und fühlen sich wie die rede und so
sehe ich wenn ich mir das mal im
nachhinein angucke auch aus der kunde
feiert das video genau so wie ich es
abgeschickt habe ich lege mich wieder
hin und versuche weiter zu schlafen
leider ohne erfolg also bereite ich mich
schon mal auf ein meeting vor welches um
13 uhr 30 stattfindet sebastian und ich
besprechen extrem langweilige aber auch
extrem wichtige dinge und ich komme erst
1830 nach hause und nachdem sich
mittlerweile schon einige in den
kommentaren beschwert haben aktiviere
ich endlich windows damit diese meldung
verschwindet damit habe ich heute nur in
neun stunden gearbeitet als ist jetzt 21
uhr und ich höre jetzt schon auf ich
werde jetzt eure länderspielen 14
stunden mit meiner freundin und einem 11
ins bett gehen
theoretisch sind wir gut in der zeit
aber viel arbeiten wir natürlich nicht
unbedingt leichter je näher sich die
woche zum ende neigt an tag 4 stehe ich
ausnahmsweise so früh auf wie geplant um
6 uhr morgens ich möchte euch mit diesem
video nicht nur zeigen wie so ein alltag
aussieht sondern auch wie er sich
anfühlt
also thomas wirklich 8 und wieder auf
seine gesundheit stellt das nicht nach
hinten hat also ich weiß nicht wie
thomas dafür noch zeit findet dass er
ihr seid vorsichtig übertreibt nicht da
gab's schon ganz viele leute die haben
sich in ein burnout reihe hasselt warum
dann zeit mit familie freunden kunden
und auch die gesundheit opfern
also bei mir fing dieses intensive
arbeiten in den sommerferien nach meine
fachabitur an für viele von euch die es
vielleicht noch eine schule sind ist es
wahrscheinlich auch die zeit wo man so
party macht so wie das die meisten
andere leute aus meiner klasse gemacht
haben und deswegen hat da schon an dass
ich da die kompletten sommerferien an
der musik wieder gearbeitet habe das
schlimmste ist nicht unbedingt das was
man nachts werden und so klar beide
sondern einfach die dinge die man nicht
machen kann
[Musik]
das ist nicht das was ich arbeite also
ich mein auf dem bau arbeiten wo er
irgendwie in der kanalisation zu
arbeiten wir sind alles bürokratie viel
anstrengender sind wo man sich
körperlich halt irgendwie auch kaputt
machen
das ist bei mir halt nicht der fall das
weiß ich dass ich sage so wie es jetzt
wenn ich jetzt mein job 40 stunden die
woche ausüben würde das wäre felix den
beruf überhaupt die tatsache dass halt
für mich stört einfach nicht reichen
kann mein anspruch ist 80 100 mehr
das macht das ganze halt so ich weiß
noch als ich einmal ein auftritt in bern
gemacht hat und ich wollte das unbedingt
machen beim turnier für mich ein idol
ist und einer der gründe warum ich hier
bin ich wusste dass ich das zeitlich
schaffen
drei nächte lang durch bach immer wenn
jemand gesagt hat er zwei drei nächte
durchgearbeitet habe ich gesagt okay es
geht und ich hab dann auch einfach weil
ich so unfassbar fertig war einfach
mittendrin angefangen zu heulen
es war halt nicht der einzige us gaap
ultra viele momente und wenn ich jetzt
zurückblicke es war es so was von wert
zu viel ich verpasst hat und so viel ich
geopfert habe und so viele momente die
ich nie wieder zurück kriegen wert und
so wie mir das tut und so viele stunden
hat nicht auch gearbeitet habe zwar
jeder als eine sekunde was wäre
ansonsten war tag 4 trotz der 15 stunden
und 20 minuten die ich an verschiedenen
projekten gearbeitet habe recht
langweilig ganz im gegensatz zu tag fünf
an dem ich bereits zur unzeit 4 uhr 30
auf stehe denn häufig nur geht's zu
freddy staffel und seinem kopf wobei
mein lieblingsessen gerungen
darauf freue ich mich schon
aber wir haben jetzt viel zeit gibt ja
auch ein grund warum zu früh
aufgestanden bin deswegen jetzt muss ich
die zweitkamera die ich bestellt habe
wenn bei meiner alten kann ja dieses
mikrofon hier nicht direkt anschließen
und die funktion brauche ich aber jetzt
dann gleich beim training will
zusammenkommen weil ich dann eine kamera
braucht und wir ja dann nicht mal mit
computern mitnehmen können
ironischerweise habe ich mich dann vor
ort dazu entschieden den ton doch nicht
mehr zu filmen jedoch die kamera musste
ja trotzdem eingestellt werden mit der
zweite kamera konnte ich danach aber
filmen wie ich mich dabei filme wie ich
dieses video schneider bisschen
kompliziert aber so seht ihr das jeden
tag noch mal ein paar stunden drauf
gegangen sind einfach um mich selber
dabei zu fehlen wie ich arbeite um sich
in diesem video zeigen zu können
das was ich jetzt gefilmt habe muss ich
natürlich auch auf meinen pc übertragen
ich hatte jetzt hier ein blödes problem
und zwar wenn ich ganz für meine form
einer speicherkarte auf meinen pc ziehen
und die festleitung ein bisschen ich
leider folgt liegt daran dass ich mir
alle meine video sind wir speichere und
die haben die jetzt von oben dass alle
speichern so kann ich mir so eine 8
terabyte festplatte zugelegt und das
müssen jetzt einbauen let's go
[Musik]
tag 6 ist samstag das heißt heute leide
ich das video hoch ich mache ja noch den
letzten feinschliff und erstelle ein
partner diese kleinen bilder werden
denke ich immer etwas unterschätzt sie
sind was aufmerksamkeit angeht mit das
wichtigste am ganzen video also sollte
es niemanden überraschen dass hinter dem
panel eines meiner videos welches eine
woche dauert zu produzieren auch immer
planung und ein bis zwei stunden arbeit
stecken wie zum beispiel auch bei dem
stand nicht für dieses video welches ihr
euch gerade anschaut dessen entstehung
er gerade sieht das video geht online
den rest des tages setzt sich vor dem
digitalen weißen blatt und arbeitete am
schnitt plan und konzept bereits für das
nächste video danach baue ich meinem
monitor um wollen wir meinen
arbeitsplatz auf und buchte drei flüge
denn für eines der nächsten videos geht
es ins ausland
wir haben jetzt samstagabend den 26
januar auf wenn wir jetzt knapp nach nur
dass wir das schon 15 eineinhalb stunden
gearbeitet jetzt noch ungefähr eine
halbe stunde dann haben wir nämlich
insgesamt ja die 104 stunden im moment
nur tatsächlich kann das sein nein kann
natürlich nicht sein ich habe nochmal
genau nachgezählt und es sollten 96
stunden und 50 minuten sein aber
immerhin das problem ist ich muss am
morgen trotz zu arbeiten ich muss morgen
konzepte fertig machen und ich muss
morgen noch drehen zusammen mit dem
sebastian und ich glaube morgen kann ich
aber gern mal ein bisschen länger zu
schlafen so es ist jetzt 11 uhr 30 ich
hab mir ein bisschen schlaf gegönnt
sollte man um 15 uhr kommt das machen
sobald er beim film hilft sebastian und
ich mache noch einige lustige bilder für
meinen instagram account erfolgt mir da
gerne wenn ihr schon instagram stories
von meiner experimenten sehen wollt
bevor das video dazu online kommt
zusammen mit dem fotoshooting einem
weiteren dreht zu hause und den
besprechen eines vertrags arbeitet
trotzdem ist 21.30 heute zehn stunden
womit wir in diesen sieben tagen auf 106
stunden und 50 minuten arbeitszeit
kommen und da ist in diesem video bisher
wahrscheinlich zu kurz gekommen ist
schlaf ist das wichtigste was es gibt
ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen wie
gefährlich schlaflosigkeit ist ich
verlinke euch dazu noch mal ein
interessantes video und ich würde sogar
beinahe jedem empfehlen möglichst wenig
zu arbeiten und sich auf sein
privatleben zu konzentrieren weil wenn
er nicht selbst ständig sagen das was
von der 100 stunden arbeitswoche wir
sind jetzt für das interview im frühling
fertig wir werden jetzt noch ein
bisschen was zu arbeiten also
das film aber ansonsten sind wir heute
durch ich fand es war relativ
interessant das wäre für mich schon sehr
verlockend gewesen jetzt irgendwie einen
film zu schauen oder irgendwie
computerspiele zu spielen und eben nicht
konzentriert und fokussiert zu arbeiten
und ja auf jeden fall wäre es auch viel
schwieriger gewesen über 100 stunden
irgendwo auf die bauzeiten dass man
natürlich klar aber was man auf jeden
fall nicht unterschätzen darf ist egal
was er macht wenn ihr das 100 stunden in
der woche macht oder länger es wird
irgendwann einfach trotzdem 100
hinnehmen wollen wenn man dafür ziemlich
lang wach bleiben muss wie am anfang
bereits erwähnt wird dieses video
unterstützt von cesc ist eine webseite
und app mit der selbstständige ganz
einfach ihre buchhaltung und steuern
automatisieren können statt hunderte
zettel in ordnung zu sortieren scannt
man mit sap das belege einfach per app
ein oder welt sie vom pc aus chef selbst
liest dann automatisch alle wichtigen
informationen heraus wodurch man direkt
alle seine belege kategorisiert hat so
wie alle seine einnahmen und ausgaben
einer einnahmenüberschussrechnung und
weitere statistiken kriegt jetzt auf den
link in der video beschreibung und
tester selbst als gratis zu 14 tage ohne
zahlungsinformationen angeben zu müssen
nächste woche werde ich jede einzelne
mahlzeit beim lieferdienst bestellen
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie sie das auf
mich und vor allem auf meinen geldbeutel
auswirkt dann abonniert gerne diesen
kanal und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]